well
nothing really like every zero of the
Alliance at their best against Allegiant
let's search the time to brush up on
invite Alliance to bring in new members
so when you're ready to get started we
have established an embassy in Stormwind
to spearhead these efforts Kings honor
their
friend as a Windwalker monk you use your
fists and your speed to overcome enemies
this builds up qi a resource that allows
you to unleash your most powerful
attacks start by using your primary
attack tiger palm to deal damage and
generate Chi
use Tiger palm on the target dummy
excellent starting combat with Tiger
palm gives you enough Chi to unleash the
powerful Rising Sun kick an attack that
uses two Chi and deal substantial damage
use it whenever it's available
use Rising Sun kick on the target dummy
good work well not as powerful as Rising
Sun kick your black out kick still packs
a punch or a kick it hits much harder
than Tiger palm so use blackout kick to
spend your extra Chi
lose blackout kick on the target dummy
you have an abundance of attacks at your
disposal Windwalker fists of fury costly
chi and does a lot of damage you will
also hit additional enemies near your
target use fists of fury whenever it's
available or if you face multiple
enemies use fists of fury on target
dummy
you're learning fast now that you have
all your primary attack abilities
together
now you have the hang of it you are fast
and agile able to zip around the
battlefield at will your primary means
of mobility is roll which causes you to
quickly roll a good distance in whatever
direction you are moving
practice using roll a few times
taking damage is part of battle but you
can tap the spiritual mists to heal
yourself or an ally use a fuse to heal
your wounds
use of fuse to replenish your health to
fool
excellent work target practice is over
here oh it's time to prove your mettle
combine all the lessons you've learned
and use them to defeat my men in combat
show me the power and agility of wind
walking
[Music]
good work now demonstrate your skill
against two foes at the same time
what can I do for you
well done next we will see hold on is
that two arms the horde is attacking
[Applause]
[Music]
well done hero you are now prepared to
do battle when you feel ready explore
your spell book and the talent tree for
additional abilities you can learn for
the Alliance
fantastic
though the Legion has fallen a new
threat Rises disturbing messages are
arriving from our operatives in
Orgrimmar join me at Stormwind keep to
discuss the matter further
[Music]
at long last the vessel that will usher
us to Argos is complete hey stop with
the hollow at once I was still journey
to bring an end to this war
[Music]
ah
it's good to see you again now that we
are all gathered let's begin as you all
know the defeat at the broken Shah was
decisive the loss of so many valiant
heroes was a terrible blow the Burning
Legion is a grave threat we must find a
way to stop their assault before all
that we hold dear can be
what was that
grand master
master
wrong are you alright
I
see you monk your struggle is for not my
forces
begone the foul creature
any more of our bakery
thank you friend my student died to
protect these Scrolls centuries of
history could have been lost
chance Don Stas was teaching a class of
youngsters when the attack began he's
one of the strongest monks I know but
even he won't be able to hold out
forever come we must rescue them
no good we don't have time to fight our
way through that horde if I focus my Chi
I believe I can get us behind their
forces quickly take my head
[Music]
this is worse than I feared we must part
ways they need my help here at the
temple Chen's class should be just to
the north across the bridges Jade
serpent watch over you
[Music]
you cannot hide from me monk try as you
might but your monastery will
try again monster
thank you for the assistance friend that
foul creature put up quite a fight
children behave yourselves so that any
story come children we must get to the
temple hero I will need your help the
complex is crawling with evil
infernal incoming watch your head
grandmaster height it is a relief to see
you Jen I'm glad to see you and the
children are safe it was all thanks to
this hero who arrived just in time to
help us out but we're not done yet
they're coming through
slow down
[Music]
excellent I have everything prepared
inside follow me
[Music]
to all members and students of our
combined schools I offer you my thanks
for joining us
the attack at the peak of serenity shows
that the Burning Legion wishes to
shatter our order they will destroy our
homes defile our sacred temples and
strive to break our spirit
but as we teetered upon the brink of
annihilation
this hero stayed with Grand Master
height and fought the demons to ensure
our survival
Grand Master height has passed on to
join the ancestors and we are left with
a void in our ranks
it seems fitting that the hero who
fought at his side who displayed courage
and valor immeasurable should succeed
him
let us all give honor to the Grand
Master may she lead us with strength and
wisdom
monks
greatest challenge still lies ahead
we will send a message of defiance to
our enemies they will not take our home
without a fight
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
you are a beacon of light in the
darkness
we are a force of balance in a chaotic
ocean